sincèrement non plus franchement ça me
fait mal au ventre de vous voir sourire
la salle et
c'est pourquoi on a parlé déjà important
mais vous étiez voilà une image de mr
devinaz vous renvoyer une image de
meilleure valeur victorieuse au lait et
nous parce que vous avez avancé sur des
sujets oui alors bien sûr ils se sont
dit mais bien sûr c'est juste qu'on n'a
pas tous filmés en fait on n'a pas passé
la soirée sont au téléphone c'était un
cocktail on a fait des choses à tout à
fait j'ai les faits justement laissez
moi parler en fait j'ai fait une vidéo
youtube où j'ai absolument sauf si vous
perdez monsieur vous êtes très su en
fait vous prenez vous avez une manière
facile harrier et très méprisant je vous
parlais déjà abaissé les femmes vous
rabaisser les chaînes s'en
est prise et on n'est pas des chiens et
des femmes d'accord et on agit on essaye
de faire des choses des choses pour
votre cause nous il ya des côtes au
qu'on veut qu'on veut aider aujourd'hui
rien vous plaignez et quand on sait
quelque chose vous vous plaignez vous
bougez vous rentrez du clip est
ce que ça vous a blessé devra couper de
tout les pc blessantes de voir des gens
comme ça vous savez très critique ça
baisse ça blesse pourquoi parce que
quand on fait rien vous critiquez
vous critiquez je vous ai fait quelque
chose nous on était là-bas on a parlé de
harcèlement on a parlé
on a parlé de désir des violences faites
aux hommes et aux femmes d'accord on a
parlé de des du délit de harcèlement sur
les homosexuels on a parlé de plein de
choses quand on est sorti de cette
réunion on a poster des liens pour aider
des gens est la plus d'un million
follower ou si elle ne serait ce qu'une
seule personne qu'elle a pu sauver hier
grâce à ses réseaux sociaux et bien je
suis fier d'être ridicule
combien maintien et l'alim géraldine
maillet moi c'est à dire que je suis
d'accord avec hollywood mais c'est rare
donc du coup c'est vrai que les deux
hommes n'ont jamais pu dire encensé
dollar jouait ces images et c'est vrai
que ça me fait ça me fait aussi un peu
mal au ventre je trouve que voilà c'est
un peu misérable c'est un peu pathétique
ça désacralise complètement la fonction
et en plus moi je vais vous dire je
pense que c'est encore plus cynique de
votre part c'est à dire je pense que
vous racheter une virginité que la télé
réalité car elles ont tellement nous
dans une mauvaise passe de raquette de
l'harcèlement de dans tous les
programmes dont on a parlé ici
d'ailleurs avec des choses absolument
terrible col a du coup on dit ah bon bah
on va se donner une virginité on va
aller voir madame chat passait très bien
on fait vachement de choses comme ça on
va tout oublié d'être amnésique mais en
fait je pense que c'est pas du tout
maîtrisée les chaînes et vous méprisez
l'analyse systématique mais qu'on fasse
vers la fin du mans qu'on le fasse bien
se fasse ma télé à la maîtriser et bien
80 de cresson d'abstention aux dernières
régionales devenant d'etion c'est énorme
ça veut dire que la france aujourd'hui
et vous ne savez pas parler aux jeunes
si aujourd'hui il ya une minorité des
antilles c'est cela aujourd'hui c'est un
hobby il regarda pour aller voter en
fera-t-il écoute moi s'il ya des
ministres aujourd'hui d'accord qui a
reçu la jeunesse pour une fois que ça
bouge quand j'ai été reçu par gabriela
talent n'a pas fait autant de scandales
peut-être est-ce que c'est une femme et
que ça choque tout le monde je ne sais
pas
c'est parce que c'est les vidéos qui ont
été sensibles à magali magail is you
play back and see you play donc sous
pression ses interventions et b mais
dès qu'on voulait je voudrais vous
semblez les grisons et céline et plus
d'un million personnes qui la suivent
s'il y en a autant c'est qu'elle a
aujourd'hui une puissance servez vous de
cette puissance pour communiquer avec
les jeunes hommes pour une fois que des
gens matthieu delormeau la galine battue
et mathieu gaye le bas que le projet de
la galice et que je sais que tu nos
films intelligents et toi aussi
certainement et le problème c'est que
vous faites tout l' inverse c'est à dire
que là ce que vous nous montrez là
pardon ces trois d'un dallage d'une
bagnole on va voir la reine chapalain
pas d'hier soir la reine machin
et là pardon est ce qu'on est bien chez
magali peut-être que l'intention est
bonne nous manque quand on regarde ça
magali on peut pas se dire que tampa bay
minustah et toi quand tu dit la dernière
fois que c'est bien la chirurgie sur les
gens que 16 ans que gérard honte a dit
quelque chose non alors s'il te plaît
mathieu la tour le 5 juin j'avais dit
une connerie mais oui c'était des
conneries tu en as dit donc moi - de
niro j'essaie de voir nos efforts mais
j'ai l'intention est bonne les
institutions et paul woods ex publier ou
pas et continuera à le faire et merci à
madame la ministre d'avoir donné la
parole à des influences us parce que
c'est une voie que magali jem a gagné
s'est étonné que les gens qui ne savent
pas ce que c'est qu'un influenceurs
montre leur que justement ce sont des
gens célèbres équipes quand on voit ça
d'ici qu'est ce que tu ai déconné
et moi je sais il est formidable magali
et ça m'ennuie de voir qu'on voit ça
alors qu'elle met pas et on n'est pas
des ministres chérif